it is time for me to play the levels
that you guys have made in s the
greatest game of all time
Lincoln bio let's see what you guys come
up with did you laugh or did another so
many Beauty roller 99.99 possible I'll
be the judge ship way possible you were
supposed to make them 99.9% impos'd
whoa you see that
whoa
that was eat that was so easy Wow
disappointed okay I'm gonna leave a
penny little I'll give it I like these
your laugh or did you lose 0:01
okay great
I guess I lost I'm gonna have this know
what the what there it is Oh Oh easy
easy
oh wow
what screw this you can't tell me how to
live my life I'm really impressed like
you guys using all the features in
delete why do I explode come on oh yeah
what it's fine I can make it I can make
it it's fine ash fine mr. puffy that's
my chick point oh yeah look at that
cheating no my dog did you have to place
it so far away easy
oh my emotion Sderot easy pretty well
designed and you know Oh God come on yes
oh okay what I lost and I lost it
well done me good job
nice match clutch appreciate it that's
the Indiana Jones okay
oh wow okay great great start
off to a fantastic oh look it's ha ha ha
oh that's cool man
you guys are so creative I'm so proud of
you oh wow I'm so good at this
where's the giant boulder though are you
kidding me what just happened oh oh I
can grab the wheels oh my god that's so
cute yes oh come on little puffer oh
yeah oh my God he's so fast yes go fast
little puffer
oh my god puffer
that's awesome no no no I'm so I'm so
impressed actually
and I was being sassy and before
but this is such a creative level and
it's only one oh God and it's only one
of the first that was so fun but always
clutch again god damn
we have pity pie your favorite thing
ever okay what is my favorite thing ever
Oh bear barrels hey I did it great job
great job Saladin what a great level Wow
was praising you guys a minute ago loops
and more version 1.2 okay what is
happening near mas probably a mass as we
say in Spain which means good fortune
happens to those who wait
oh god this car is too good man
mm look at that
oh wow look I did the loop you're
welcome
oh god oh god oh god hey oh wow what is
happening
nah a no shortcut shortcut
oh god it's fine I may be on fire
never mind I died way I'm sushi I'm
sushi come on you can do it sushi sushi
sushi nah
damn it Game of the Year you can play a
sushi
come on come on
I missed it then no I did it okay cool
what is this vehicle oh it's the flame
one get that speed mr. puffer come on
come on my back what the heck why do I
explode oh if you charge it all the way
you explode I didn't damn it
whoo whoo that's what I'm talking about
that's what I'm talking about
go puffer girl do you mean speed Oh
oh come on you point it down I'm
just gonna keep going
screw you I'm pretty sure I miss
something important
oh great ow I'm fine I'm fine don't
worry about it don't worry just don't
worry but Oh sure cut yeah
Oh God Oh nailed it nailed it
nailing it killing it killing it man
you don't live a legend mr. puffer look
at that
hi that's I did that on purpose don't
worry guys these loops are really cool
here we go another great level but it
took me four minutes Jesus buff and
muffin well done on making a great level
barrels of fun everybody I wonder what's
gonna happen
[Applause]
I'm not having barrels of fun oh my god
oh my god I made it what the hell hahaha
screw you I had given up go forth
mr. puff you can do it you can do it you
can it easy easy easy easy you can do it
easy worst level I have ever seen in my
life
pity pies challenge challenge accepted
oh no I made this level I made this
shitty level you can't actually get
through this bit look I did it let's not
play that one what the hell is this
PewDiePie is how how dare you oh God
up
my god it's impossible hey I did it I
did it thank you
now what oh god oh god oh god oh there
we go
I did it No
Oh No stupid stupid 'banahna a Palmas
kart 64 did you guys have that show
bananas in pyjamas banana a Pyramus
what the heck is that I'm raising a
banana and I can't let him win come on
come on come on come on come on ma hell
yeah Oh God
stop I can't let this stupid banana win
no the banana has a rocket he's cheating
oh my god this is so dumb I'm not gonna
lose to a banana
all right I'll lose to jacksepticeye
fine a banana
over my dead damn dead body did I do it
of course I did it what kind of question
today
excuse me mr. banana hot dog you can
there you go thank you that was amazing
well done keV very creative really proud
of you guys and your creativity make
some more levels for me and I'll play it
in the next episode if you enjoyed
watching you leave a like if you enjoyed
the game check it out it's out on Steam
early access appreciate all the support
and it's always say awesome for us